how are you holding up here you got you
got three little ones right yeah three
little girls we're okay you know 70
some-odd days in the quarantine we're
starting to kind of find some structure
and sometimes a normal seat through all
this stuff but uh step definitely been
it been a strange time no doubt are they
do they have just like running around
like crazy I mean is it do they make it
easier or more difficult to create when
you're at home you know I just think as
a parent for these times like you have
to get super creative you know I mean
you got to just make up games out of
nowhere he is entertained and um we've
been watching a lot of movies and
getting outside quite a bit and but it's
been a blast man up you know been
talking about this today a lot but I've
never been at home this much in ten
years so in that on that side of things
it's been really great to get to put my
kids to bed every night wake up with
them and and get to hang out with him
more than I than I would if I was on the
road I mean even that in itself is an
adjustment right I mean it's something
that you I'm sure longed for but to be
able to have it is a completely
different story right yeah yeah no doubt
man absolutely I mean you know during
during this whole time it's just been
for us our main our main thing is waking
up and being like we're gonna live today
for today because we have no idea what's
gonna happen tomorrow or next week or
when all this is gonna end so you might
as well make the most of the you know
the circumstances that you're given so
that's we're trying to do yeah you said
you've been watching a lot of movies how
many times they made you watch Scoob so
far we've watched it twice today
actually it's amazing like you know all
you gotta do is put a song in the movie
and your kids want to watch that one
over and over and over and over so um
but it was a great movie been watching a
bunch of Disney Plus catching up on the
classics and some of the new releases
too but my kids do what they loved
watching movies that's core you know one
where my kids see me on TV or anything
else they're like like they do I mean
every award show you most of the time
they're not with me so they're usually
at home with like my mom or Lauren's mom
and their water performance and my mom
will always send us a video of our kid
of my kids dancing and from the TV when
when I couldn't get performed so at
least I hope that keeps me cool up into
their teenage years yeah I'm sure I
think fans of yours like are they
playing your songs all the time to dance
into your music dude it's all they
listen to they like they make me not
like my records anymore because that's
all we listen to so but they
listen to my tunes yeah yeah you posted
a photo on Instagram recently showing
like what is like you know recording
during this this health crisis are you
finding it easier to be creative because
of the time at home what's the process
like for you right now uh in the
beginning I didn't know what in the
world to do like I was like how are we
gonna write songs anymore how are we
gonna record songs but you know at least
for the Nashville community and a lot of
other communities that I've seen like
you just kind of thrive during times of
weirdness you know so I started writing
on zoom' and I taught myself how to use
Pro Tools and record my own vocals and
all that kind of stuff so even though we
can't be with each other that at least
as songwriters and artists we're still
getting to create and I feel like when
you're kind of put under the under the
wheel like this you kind of are more
creative in a way because you're kind of
forced to be so I feel like you know
that the way I've been writing songs has
been a lot cooler and has forced me to
be a lot more creative than I was you
know previous to this yeah it's it's
been unfortunate that the Nashville
community has had to struggle with
several things going on the last in the
last little while when you find yourself
looking to someone to lean on who is
that person who who helps you out my
wife is my rock man I mean my family's
great and they they come over and we
hang out quite a bit but my wife is
definitely my rock you know so during
this she was the one kind of coaching me
being like hey you know I understand
that this is not normal and I know that
you want to be on the road but like you
know you got you kind of have to look at
the positive side of this stuff too like
even though you can't tour you are get
to spend triple the amount of time with
your family you know so I think when
things do but go back to normal for me I
just think from the fansite in from my
side people are gonna be so much more
hyped up to go to a show because they've
been deprived of it for a year um so for
me when I get back on the road I think
it's gonna make it that much sweeter and
and my wife has been a great support
system and encouragement for sure to
meet her in the Sun yeah it takes
someone usually from yeah obviously
outside of your own your own head to be
able to let you know when it's okay to
take a break like was it you know you
loved to work obviously and you loved to
be on the road yeah how difficult of a
decision was it for you to actually
cancel the tour I mean it's the hardest
thing in the world to do but at the same
time there wasn't
wasn't much of a choice you know when
you're watching all your buddies and and
even you know around the world you know
having to cancel tours and and all that
kind of stuff like I think of the day
you have to do what's the safest play
for you and for your fans you know and
for us and a lot of other artists it was
it was to cancel you know wait we didn't
cancel we postponed it to next year but
it was the safest thing to do not the
Tour this year it's just unfortunate man
because you know that's some for a lot
of people like that's that that's the
highlight of their summer it's the
highlight of mine for sure you know yeah
I'm getting geared up for outdoor
festivals and outdoor shows is one of my
favorite things in the world and I'm
just gonna miss it this year man but I
like I said I do think it's gonna make
next year a lot sweeter yeah I mean in a
strange way though fans have really been
blessed by a lot of music in this time I
mean a lot of musicians creators artists
that have been stuck at home have been
able to reach out to each other but you
did would be a light and create amazing
music for people what was it what was it
like why did you want to do that and how
did you get a hold of all those people
to go over there well I'll tell you it's
a lot easier to get people to feature on
your song when they're not busy uh-huh
you know when they're when they're sit
at home - they're kind of like begging
for people to be like hey call me I'll
do anything I mean I know that I've been
at that point - like hey whatever y'all
need me to do I'll do it just just to be
able to do something to use my brain and
be creative but uh you know be a light
for me what was a way to kind of share
kind of what I was feeling about the
world during this time - and and I feel
like that song has brought a lot of
encouragement in joy to a lot of people
but I've never met which is which I
think is what's so cool about music is
that you can reach people to the ends of
the globe you know with words that
you're feeling and somehow it can
translate into their lives but um you
know even though we can't play a real
show it's been cool to just to watch a
lot of artists do in-home performances
and Instagram lives and put there's been
I thought there's been so much content
released from artists that are just
writing their face off and recording it
releasing it and and you know I think a
lot of people are getting creative on
how they can still stay connected with
their fans and to me I feel more
connected with my fans now than I ever
have
yeah I think it's gonna be a very
exciting time in a little while to see
all the amazing music that's coming out
of this right yeah no doubt man I mean I
feel like there's just a lot of emotions
going around and I think a lot of
artists and songwriters are figuring out
a way to channel that
music and soething you're gonna hear you
know a lot of artists best stuff when
their new records come out yeah are you
getting a lot of people reaching out to
you saying that beer can't fix means a
lots of them right now yeah well it's
just funny because people are like man
you have two polar opposite songs out be
a light and beer can't fix but they both
kind of they both do their own thing you
know
so beer can't taste kind of helps you'd
be like well you know what this is I'm
just gonna take this on the chin and
this is what it is and be a light
hopefully helps you too so just to learn
how to be kindness in a world that's
kind of dark right now so kind of both
ends of the spectrum yeah how are you
it's just personally like with you and
with the kids how are you guys um
communicating to them what is happening
right now and keeping them from I know I
know with my own kids oftentimes I'll
ask questions and not in terms I'll get
sad because of what's going on how do
you guys handle it I don't know how old
your kids are but monitor monitor just
under the age I think of fully
understanding what's happening mmm and I
put my oldest one to bed the other night
and since she's really sad she was like
daddy why can't I go see my Gigi or my
or my grandparents and I was just like
well it's really hard to explain but
there's there's just a sickness going
around and and we need to we need to
keep everybody safe by not touching each
other and washing our hands and you know
it'll go back to normal at some point
but but right now it's just a weird time
you know and explaining that to a four
year oldest is a really hard thing to do
but they're starting to you know they're
starting to kind of get the vibe of like
this is kind of what normal is right now
so I think that the more normal we can
make this you know I think when we come
out of this I think our kids will be
like man that was so strange but I'm so
glad I can go touch my grandparents now
and I'm glad we can go to a restaurant
now and go back to the movie theater and
all that kind of stuff so it's just
funny how kids brain processes such a
global you know weirdness yeah well I
mean everyone's going through it and
they have doing things but I'm grateful
for artists like you putting out music
that are helping people get through
whatever they're going through so man
that's all we can do right now I
appreciate you saying that
awesome well thanks for your time you
know and get back those kids I will
thanks man have a go in it
you